Okay, one last thing I'd like to look at before
we move on to some more advanced query topics. Is the
ability to specify a projection document in addition to our query
document for calls to find. Now, what projection does is it
essentially describes the shape we would like documents to take in
the result set. I'm also going to break this out a
little bit here with the query and projection variable, and pass
those to find, instead of directly passing the dictionary that we
constructed to find. I point this out merely because we'll
see this later on in the lesson, and I don't want
anyone to be confused. Now, let's imagine that instead of getting
back all of the documents for our query specifying constraints on
manufacture and class, we actually are only interested in getting the
name of the document back. Well, we could simply print out
the name down here. But another way we can do that
is by specifying a projection as a second parameter to find.
And what that's going to do is say, all of the result
documents that come back, instead of having their full contents, I only
want to see name. No, by default, unless we explicitly say, I
don't want to see the ID field, we'll also get ID. So
that's why I've got ID set to zero here. Okay? So the
way we do this, is, essentially, we specify all the fields for
the documents in this collection. And then specify whether or not we
want them to occur in a result set. Alright? Let's run this.
Alright and here we can see that the documents
we get back simply have the name field in them.